Peter, you brought your own soccer ball with you to school today?
I sure did!
Good Old Spots here is my lucky soccer ball.
He never misses the goal when I kick him.
Awesome, let's play soccer during recess.
Ok, I love playing soccer anytime.
It's my favorite sport.
My favorite sport is baseball.
I like hitting a home run and winning the game.
Winning is fun, but it's okay to lose too as long as you try your best.
I guess so.
Win or lose, you should be a good sport by always being nice to the other team.
No one likes a sore winner.
You're right.
I guess it doesn't matter who wins or loses as long as we have fun.
Hopefully, today at recess everyone will be a good sport.
No sore losers or winners.
Well, there are definitely going to be winners.
Because I'm feeling super quick today so you and Old Spots better watch out.
You hear that Old Spots?
Let's teach Chris how much fun it is to lose sometimes.